a new podcaster as well who i loved
working with
uh when we did a few combines together
at nfl network
and he is a natural uh in this business
of talking and communicating
nfl tight end conversations with greg
olson the host of te1 where all podcasts
can be acquired from the seattle
seahawks greg olson how are you greg
i'm doing well it's always good to talk
to you how's it going how's your family
you know we're doing good it's actually
an off day here for us we had a
mock scrimmage yesterday so we are
actually enjoying the park out here in
seattle and
kind of just walking around and enjoying
the neighborhood everyone's doing good
we're
figuring out school as everyone across
the country is but
everyone's doing good and everyone's
adjusting thanks
of course and as you know i like to take
care of my teammates here uh the rich
eisen show
i'm going to start off chris brockman
who uh you've met a few times uh
with this program he's a die-hard
patriot fan he's pissed you're not with
the patriots
that's 100 percent true boy is a team
really could use you did
did that ever materialize never they
ever knock on your door did that ever
happen i know you're happy where you are
but i just need to take care of my god
thanks across the way hear that
yeah and uh you know i i think in past
years there
there were times where that almost came
to be you know i remember being called
in
by jerry angelo back before they did
draft before they drafted
gronkowski in 2010 and said they had a
trade on the table to
to trade for me and then of course that
didn't happen and they ended up taking
gronkowski which turned into a smart
move by their part but uh
there was always kind of this weird
thing where everyone always thought i
was going to end up there and then i
think
um you know prior to cam signing there
there was a lot of speculation that
maybe me and him would play together
again but uh
no this time around when i was a free
agent we didn't really have much
communication with them
um this time around and uh i couldn't be
happier though to be here in seattle but
it does give me great pleasure to see
those clips online of cam
dancing during warm-ups and seeing him
enjoy it because it just brings back a
lot of memories man he's
he's uh he's one of a kind and i saw it
for nine years and he's not going to
change and it's cool to see
before i get to your one-of-a-kind
quarterback of the moment
uh greg i do want to keep you if you
don't mind uh in the role of
uh analyst and paparazzi and obviously
now you're a podcast host so you're
excellent at this i give you the floor
on cam
and why why is there a disconnect
between what you know as cam and what
fans perceive of him
do you think greg you know i think
that's a good question i think it's a
question we've all been
kind of asked and answering since 2011
since people first first saw him and i
think a big part of it was
you know people weren't used to seeing
the quarterback position played
the way he played it um with the with
the
you know the theatrics and the running
around and the celebrations and the
pregame dancing
and like all that stuff was very new and
i think a lot of people
fit into the the box of how they wanted
their quarterback to act and how they
wanted him to hold his press conferences
and what they wanted them to wear and
here comes this kind of trailblazer of a
personality who we're used to
if he was a wide receiver we've seen a
hundred of them right we've
we've seen guys like him you know play
wide out and play defensive back who
have big personalities and
and are you know super entertaining on
the field as they play
but now here was a guy playing
quarterback and i think
it just took people a while to kind of
wrap their heads around it
and you know as teammates and as
somebody who knows them as well as i do
you know i always took every opportunity
to make sure people understood
you know what you see and if you you
know in the dancing and all that stuff
when it comes time to playing and
preparing and practicing
and training and all the stuff that that
really matters about playing quarterback
cam checks all those box boxes twice you
know and
guys that played with him loved him as a
teammate loved his competitive spirit
and practice his competitive spirit in
the games
um you know personally obviously i've
been on the record a million times about
what he's meant to my career and
and how much i've enjoyed him as a
person and just enjoy being being a
teammate of his so
um you know i i hope i hope other than
in week two i hope he has a great season
um you know i i want to see him bounce
back and i want to see him kind of
answer a lot of the people that have
doubted him
that said um your choice of seattle
how much did russell wilson who's pretty
damn special in his own right
and wasn't a number one overall pick
like cam um
and a national champion like like cam uh
a self-made man a little bit more you
could say about your
your current quarterback how much did uh
playing with him factor into you
signing where you signed it was a huge
factor
um you know russ was a guy that i've you
know had a lot of respect for
from a distance you know from across the
field from uh you know from a
competitive standpoint playing against
him so many times there
um over the years and just just seeing
how he carried himself just seeing how
he competed to seeing how
you know no matter what the score was he
took that field thinking they were going
to come back and win
i remember playoff game back in 2015. we
jump
up 31 nothing at halftime in the
divisional round i mean we're rolling
bank america our stadium's rocking you
know we have them dead to rights and
we had to recover an on-site kick to win
the game at the end just to eke it out
just because
you know they had russell and you know
they had a lot of other good players too
don't get me wrong
defensively and whatnot but you know
there was just something unique and
special about
about him and everybody i had talked to
echoed those same sentiments that i felt
in person competing against them and
uh all that stuff has just you know
couldn't have been more accurate now in
my time getting to know him as a person
and
and being able to learn and grow and and
learn this offense and try to find my
place here
um he's just been you know there's a
reason why he's
he's the best if not amongst the
conversation of being the best in the
game right now and he's uh
he's he's just special his communication
his
ability to to get guys to do things the
right way
to show that example day in and day out
he he was a huge reason that i came here
and uh i've been very fortunate to to
play with another
you know special quarterback greg olsen
here on the rich eisen show we'll get to
your podcast in a second
um you've been on super bowl team
you've been on you've been in the super
bowl you've been on a team that made the
super bowl greg right you've been on
teams that have
tried to make the super bowl you've been
on teams that struggled so you've been
through the
you know in your 14 years you've seen it
all seattle we saw what they did last
year
uh now uh here's another year in
and you know the program everybody knows
exactly
what is expected of them and pete
carroll's been there for
a very long time is how how
do you see this team i know you don't
usually speak of super bowls prior to a
season
but how do you see this team greg super
bowl
what do you think you know as you said i
think you know so many people have said
to me you know what a great choice going
out to seattle you can have your you
know you have a chance to go out win a
super bowl at the end
you know and all that stuff is true i
think the reality is
there's a there's a handful plus teams
every year
that year in year out barring a
catastrophic injury or
a come out of nowhere kind of story
there's a handful of teams
plus a few more that are always in the
mix
to be there at the end and whether that
culminates in a super bowl whether that
culminates in a playoff run to what
extent
i think nobody can predict i think teams
you know
going into the season say you know we
have a shot we we are talented we have
the right pieces at the right position
right
quarterback the organizational support
coaching
you know just the consistency of the of
the program consistency of the
organization you know seattle checks all
those boxes but
as we all know year in and year out it
doesn't guarantee you anything um i
couple years you know 2015 year in
carolina i thought we
i think we all thought we had a chance
to be good i don't know if any of us
thought we were going to win 17 games
and then on the flip side in 2016 same
team
pretty much everything the same and we
thought we were just going to do it
again and we went 6 and 10.
you know so i think so much of being
consistent in this league is being
honest with yourself about resetting
every single offseason and saying
the previous year the previous 10 years
they mean nothing you know we need to re
we need to regroup we need to reassess
we need to be honest with ourselves
and say here's what it's going to take
all that work it took last year to make
that run
it's going to be that plus some and uh
they've done as good a job out here as
as doing that you know for 10 years i
think they've been in the playoffs nine
times or
whatever it's you know it's unheard of
in today's nfl so i think
so far it's been great i think we're
very talented i think defensively we
have some really good players some
really good pieces and traditionally
they're you know seattle they know what
they're doing on defense that's for sure
and offensively i think we got a lot of
talent i think
dk metcalf is really really yeah he's
special
i'll tell you what i i i knew from afar
he was good
now seeing him and watching him grow and
develop i mean he has a chance
to be i mean i don't like throwing
around superlatives and comparisons but
i mean you're talking like a calvin
johnson type
guy big fast aggressive you know he's
got a ways to go to obviously reach what
calvin achieved but from just
an approach standpoint he every day he
wants to learn every day he's trying to
figure out ways
to improve his game and then physically
he checks every box you've ever
thought of for wide receivers um so his
developments can be really interesting
to watch he's had some unbelievable days
at camp
our running backs our offensive i mean
we have a lot of good pieces and um
when we when you have the guy behind
center like russ who can
you know kind of make magic happen
you're always gonna be in every game and
you're always going to have a chance
and i think that's all every player asks
for greg olsen here
on the rich eisen show um you had a
former teammate who
um isn't there anymore because he was
trying to be somewhat inventive and
and not following the covet rules um
so and and i'm that's uh i guess
what chris i'm putting it somewhat uh
mildly right there i'm trying to
go through the front door and i just but
i read about your team
it seems like your team is locked in and
saying we are not going to
we're going to be about football from
here on out we are not going to have
anybody do anything stupid
do you think we're we're going to have a
a a 17 week season in the nfl regular
season
greg in this cove at 19 world what do
you think
you know i do and whether that's the
just the optimism
you know the optimist in me um speaking
um i really in my heart believe that
we're gonna get through it i think the
last five six weeks of camp
i think the the data and the numbers of
the the amount of testing that we've
done
and the the fraction of you know the
fraction of positive tests and then even
some of the positive tests we all knew
you know we all heard the story came out
to be false positives um
you know i think the data and and the
track record suggests that we're doing a
really good job now when you start
introducing travel and
going to different cities i think
that'll be the next step i think weeks
you know the first week or two of the
season when guys start going on the road
and
there's transportation and going to and
from stadiums i think that could but
i think when you look around the country
it seems like there's a lot of positive
developments going on it seems like
um you know the you know positivity rate
is
continuing to decline and cases are
declining and all that and then within
our little bubble of the nfl
the same is the same to be said so it's
all about guys making good decisions
it's all about guys
understanding that they're not only
representing themselves when they make
those decisions but they have they're
kind of holding the whole team in their
hands
and i think our guys have really done a
good job pete does a great job of
communicating that
multiple times a day and just stressing
the importance of
of what that means to protect the team
and uh
knock on wood so far so far the results
have been really positive
man and then pete we'll talk about
communicating what he what he
his soliloquy on voting and society and
white people in this country need to
quote unquote be coached up
was truly moving over the weekend do you
think greg there's already a
conversation that what we saw in the nba
with players um saying we're not we're
not playing for the moment because we
need to focus on what's going on
in the real world do you think that
could happen in the nfl
greg you know i think in today's day i
think anything is possible
i don't think i think it would be naive
and
kind of short-sighted to eliminate
anything from the table
i think those are discussions that are
going on amongst
various groups of people various teams i
think their conversations
obviously those are conversations just
going on throughout society
and certain people are going to feel
differently certain people are going to
feel certain
you know certain acts are going to get
greater attention
are going to get greater traction and
everyone has that right i think the nba
felt that at the time and in the wake of
the latest incident in wisconsin that
that was what was in their best interest
for the movement i think they have every
right to make those decisions and it was
powerful and it
and obviously it got the world's
attention um how the nfl and how
individual teams decide
i think will be unique to each team i
think it'll be unique to each team's
four set of leaders and the way that
they feel it's best to
to move forward towards progress and to
move forward towards
you know implementing a lot of the
change that everyone is calling for so
i i don't think anything's off the table
but i also
haven't heard like a resounding um
kind of message or voice that that's
something that's heavily being
considered
so as i sit here today i would be
surprised at least
within the bubble i've been in but um
but i don't think anything should be
taken off the table at this point
greg olson of the seahawks here on the
rich eisen show and everybody who's been
hearing our conversation so far knows
why greg has already got a gig with fox
sports when uh when you're done with
playing as well as
uh you're perfect for this podcast world
as well
te1 um you're talking with folks like
shannon sharp and ozzy newsome and mike
ditka and tony gonzalez as well as
kittle and
kelsey curran also it's it's a tight end
only
world on your pod craig
it is so the the idea behind it as it
was kind of the idea was kicked around
is you know when you look at the nfl
today and you mentioned kelsey and
kittle and you got zakarts
who easily could have been part of this
conversation so many guys throughout the
league you know
the tight end position really for the
first time in history
is a superstar driven position you know
there's household names not just of your
favorite team
but if you're just a fan of the nfl you
know who these guys are
they're playing for super bowls they're
you know getting thousand yard seasons
year in and year out
and we wanted to tell that story you
know it wasn't always like that you know
we
so we went back we started with mike
ditka we released the mike dikka and the
ozzie newsome
um as the first two episode interviews
uh last week
and we kind of set this set the bar in
1960 when when
dikka came in the league and uh kind of
took it by storm playing a position that
nobody really even knew what it meant
and uh we talked about with ozzie newsom
who kind of carried that torch forward
and uh it brings us to tomorrow we'll
launch shannon sharp who
was just awesome anyone who's ever
listened to him or you know he's not
short of
opinions and short of stories and you
know just the guys that we got to tell
this
kind of evolution of the tight end
position really exceeded my wildest
imagination
and uh from shannon we go to tony
gonzalez you know we start out with four
hall of famers in a row
nice and i mean it was just it was just
so cool to hear them open up and
and share their stories of their
upbringings it was so relevant to
today's time here you know talking with
ozzy
about growing up in the south during
segregation and shannon touching on it
when i talked to shannon it was shortly
after the george floyd
um tragedy and and everybody you know
the movement and everybody was
you know the world was kind of an uproar
and and here i am talking to shannon and
he's touching on
his life growing up in georgia and it
was just
it was so timely just the way it worked
out
um he was really able to share some
really unique perspectives so we're
we're really excited about it the
response and the feedback of the of the
series has so far been
really positive and uh we're gonna start
getting into some really fun
conversations some tough conversations
with shannon and tony kittle um kelsey
so we got some cool guys coming up the
next couple weeks
i love i love pretty much everybody you
mentioned i just love
their great personalities great stories
i'm sure
um everybody should be checking out te1
and and just you know greg i like to
leave people in a better position
um i think if you don't mind you know
you should begin to
expand the the world of guest
possibilities for instance
any anybody that's remotely close to the
tight end position should be
uh open to the world by that i mean
maybe will ferrell should come on
because if i'm not mistaken
he played you in one of the first
zooms of the the seattle seahawk
off-season workout program correct where
he did he was introduced you were
supposed to be on the zoom and then pete
carroll brought in will ferrell as you
right greg didn't that happen he did and
i yeah and
and i had no idea was coming come on
called me a couple
he i had no idea pete called me a couple
minutes before he's like hey i'm going
to need you to bear with me during this
team meeting
i'm going to introduce you but i just i
don't need you to say anything
i was like that's interesting so now we
hang up
five minutes later i joined the zoom and
i'm like racking my brain like
what's gonna happen like you know why do
i why am i not allowed to talk right and
sure enough uh will ferrell comes on and
he does a
spot-on impersonation for anybody who
hasn't seen it it's a spot-on
impersonation um so i think he talked to
somebody because somebody gave him like
all my mannerisms
my quirks it was uh it was really well
done
and it was a it was a fun way to kind of
meet the team
that was your introduction to the team
was that really that day
yeah that was that was it that was it
was one of our first
team zoom calls you know and and
everybody got a kick out of it and
it was uh it was really well done i i
it was real for anybody who hasn't seen
it they should go find it now because it
was uh
it was pretty funny yeah it's out there
in the uh probably on seahawks.com
there's uh
youtube as well uh thanks for the call
greg i'm glad to hear everything is
great with you you sound great
and uh i can't wait to see you crush it
up there great spot i appreciate it
though we got jamal
you got jamal adams too i mean my gosh
everything's looking up for you greg
olsen
i like it hopefully he's got to keep it
going okay keep it going we're almost
there knocking on wood for you thanks
for the call greg appreciate it take
care
greg olson